[Music]
so for everybody's favorite communist
holiday labor day we thought we'd come
outside and uh do a little cookout again
with our favorite company good ranchers
who have supplied all the food and we're
also we've returned to my roots in my
old studio
here behind in front of the sheet now
that we're here actually i'm not exactly
sure why we have this sheet here it
doesn't make a lot of sense but we have
it so we're just going to roll with it
and uh you know as we tend to do as any
good dad as i'm flipping burgers here
we're going to i'm going to give a
little bit of advice based on
the tick tock marriage advice that's out
there um so it's really gonna be more of
a corrective we'll watch some of those
videos i'll tell you why they're wrong
and then i'll tell you
what the actual good advice is so let's
go let's get started
what is the best age to get married it's
not in your 20s it's a better idea for
you to get married in your 30s because
you've gone through all the changes and
you are more settled you come into your
own in your 30s and i think that's a
very good time to get married i got
married when i was 30 and i'm married
for
41 years now all right so that's uh
relationship advice
from a divorce lawyer so that we know
we're already on the wrong foot here
like taking relationship advice from a
divorce lawyer
it's like i don't know
taking advice from a shark on where the
best swimming spots are there's a
there's a real conflict of interest
there and so she says well you should
wait till you're in your 30s to get
married and she knows because she
is very good at she's very good at
breaking up marriages helping marriages
dissolve and so we're supposed to take
her advice
now look
you can get married at any time in your
adult life and potentially have a
successful marriage there are people who
get married in their 60s and you know
it's death to deal with part now it's
that way it's kind of easier actually
when you get married very late because
you don't have very long until you're
dead and so you can have that success in
that sense
kind of running out the clock i guess
but as in general like what should we
advise people to do as a general policy
we should obviously advise them to get
married younger
and there are a couple reasons for that
one reason is that biology exists okay
despite what we hear from the left
biology is a real phenomenon
and what that means is that our
biological clocks are ticking especially
for women so if you wait until your
mid-30s to get married it might be too
late to have a family my wife is married
with our number five and six right now
okay
and uh because we like to do we like to
double up when we have kids
and they're already telling you she's 35
they told her this is this technically
counts as a geriatric pregnancy at the
age of 35. that's real so she's like
that's what it is so you're gonna wait
until you're in geriatric pregnancy mode
to get married to begin with doesn't
make a lot of sense and also the other
point
is that if you get married younger then
you're building a life with someone
rather than building your adult life
first and then trying to
inject somebody else into it and that
can cause problems because then you feel
like well this is mine this is my life
and you feel like they're intruding on
it there's real value in starting young
and like being on the ground floor
together as you build your life together
so that's terrible advice
let's uh check out the next one
this has completely changed our
relationship so at the beginning of
every month you write down new ways that
you can love your person either things
you can do for them or things you can do
with them and you cut up the pieces of
paper you fold it and you put it in
something to pull from and then every
morning you both choose one piece of
paper and find time just to do that one
thing it forces you to be intentional
and it works do it is it
oh it's a lesbian
thing
all right
this is right we're doing a uh a cookout
in the parking lot there's someone
loading a truck line so i don't know if
you can hear that but anyway so what we
hear from from from that relationship
advice is that you wanna
write little cute things you're gonna do
for each other and put it on a slip of
paper and then put it into a hat and
pick it out of the hat at the beginning
of the day
this is what happens when you get
relationship advice from someone who's
never like been in a relationship
that's the kind of idea it's like if
you're 16 years old that's the kind of
idea your girlfriend might have and it's
just it's
in reality like living your everyday
life you're not gonna stick first of all
you're not gonna stick to a plan like
that
if my wife came to me and said oh we're
gonna we're gonna write our goals for
each other on slips of paper and we're
gonna pick it out of a what i'm not
going to do that what
the hell are you talking about we got a
lo i got we have kids to deal with like
we don't have time for this
also
if you can think of good ways to act
towards your spouse
just do that don't don't write it on
paper because how does that work it's
like if your wife comes to you and says
oh i want you to i want you to listen
more to me you're not listening enough
and then i say oh sorry i wasn't on the
slip of paper today i did so i didn't
pull it out that's why i can't do that
one
if you have good ideas of how you're
supposed to treat your spouse
just enact it right away start living
that
don't try to turn it into a cute little
game
more terrible advice what else we got my
husband and i recently changed something
in our communication and let me tell you
it has changed everything our new house
rule is every time that you have some
constructive criticism for the other
person you have to lead with two
positive reinforcing comments one has to
be physical and one has to be mental for
example the other day my husband decided
that he didn't like the way i dried off
our cutting knives so instead of just
coming to me after a long day of being a
mom and abruptly telling me that he
needs me to dry off the knives better he
started with the two compliment rules he
said hannah i can tell that you have
been working really hard as a mom this
week and that does not go unnoticed and
then he told me that my butt looks cute
in my jeans do you think that you could
maybe do a little bit of a better job
drying off these cutting knives in the
end this small change in our
communication has drastically changed
the dynamic of everything this week has
felt lighter we've had more fun and i
feel like we've gotten in less fights so
i hope this helps uh no it doesn't help
okay that [ __ ] advice does not help
first of all that's a trap men to begin
with so when when your wife comes to you
and says oh no i can take constructive
criticism but just say something
positive first that's not it's not gonna
work in practice okay because you could
you could you could lead with
50 things you like about them you could
spend an hour listing honey this is what
i love about you and then just put an
hour listing stuff as soon as you get to
the bad thing that's all that's that's
the headline right there and all the
other stuff
dissipates okay it evaporates so just
don't believe that in the first place
and then on the other end of it as a man
i don't want that don't come to me
like i don't i know the setup just get
to the point so as soon as my wife comes
in and says uh honey you know i
i really like how you ironed your pants
this morning
and i think you're a nice person okay
yeah what you're about to criticize me
get to get to it come on what is it
gonna be what did i do this time
just
what what helps more in a marriage take
it from me
is just to be direct and get to the
point cut to the chase
if you have a problem say it and then
you move on with your lives because
everything we're hearing so far from
tick tock is just ways of like
drawing all this out and making it into
a bigger deal than it needs to be
just say
she didn't do a good job drying off the
cutting knives is that the complaint
that seems like a pretty petty thing to
complain about in the first place but if
that's an issue for you just go and tell
her honey dry the cutting knives next
time okay look at the streaks on it
you're causing problems that's all you
got to do
no problem
all right what do we got
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
that's right i got the point first of
all
i'm just burning the hell out of these
burgers
it's not my fault this is
this tick tock is distracting me don't
use tick-tock while you while you're
over an open flame okay that's the first
bit of advice
second is if you're making a tic-tac
video why just say what you want once
again this is the theme get to the point
what is the thing on tik-tok now where
they don't even speak they just look
into the camera while their words come
up on the screen i did that a few weeks
ago because i was i'm a laryngitis
survivor so if you have laryngitis if
you're mute or something i understand it
but i don't think that's the case for
her
and what's the point that she's making
she's saying uh well
women sometimes feel unappreciated and
then she's going through the list of all
the
things that you know the wife deals with
and she's dealing with the kids and she
has to clean the house and all that kind
of stuff
and and i get it
but
the thing that will kill a marriage
more than anything is self-pity okay so
that's what when i watch that video
i don't see a woman who's like put upon
an oppressed everything she's listing
that's just part of life we all have
roles in life
and work is part of life so whether
you're man or woman whatever you're
doing in the house you're gonna have to
work
when you have kids even more so
it just it takes work
so you're working the husband's work
everybody's working all the time we've
got the sad piano music and she's
listing all these really normal things
she has to do in her life
i'm not seeing a problem of a woman
being oppressed i'm seeing a problem of
someone who is drowning in self-pity
to the point of their like even putting
their own story up on tick-tock with sad
piano music in the background
get over yourself
realize that life is work
life is suffering
and once you come to accept that you'll
have if not joy
maybe some contentment
i say this to my wife all the time she
loves it when i say that to her
what's next you know how when you ask me
what i want to eat and then i say i
don't know
and then we go in circles
and then sometimes we even get an
argument about that or like you ask me
like what i want to do and then i'm like
i don't know and then it's the notebook
scene
yeah it's not that simple i feel like i
i do know but i'm saying i don't know
because i wish you would just be in your
masculine and take the lead and it makes
me feel like i have to make all the
decisions and decide everything and it
like it kind of pisses me off and so i'm
saying i don't know because i wish you
would just
take the lead
okay so you want me to take the lead
actually more
and especially in decision making
processes yeah because
you feel like you're being in the
masculine role you know the irony is i'm
trying not to be
toxic masculine i'm trying not to be
disrespectful and so i'm trying to make
sure and give you an equal say and equal
you know option and opinion i'm actually
trying to
help you feel included in that
decision-making process but what i'm
hearing is actually that you don't
necessarily want that
yeah i mean i don't feel like you need
to worry about being domineering unless
you were going to like force me to do
something like no i said we're doing
this today like you don't have a say
that would be domineering but when you
take the lead and then you're open to me
being like no actually you know i don't
want that then that's really healthy so
but i actually really prefer you to take
the lead to make decisions so i can be
in my feminine and i actually love most
of the decisions that you make in it
feels good awesome all right
good
so
finally a little bit of sanity
you see glimmers of it every once in a
while on tick-tock and uh
i never thought i'd find it on a channel
called what was that channel called the
yoga
the yoga couple
well so
before we get that here's the bad news
the woman is married to this guy and she
wants her to be masculine
well unfortunately for you you married a
guy with long hair who does yoga so
that was out the window to begin with
but now it's actually very sad because
she's like i married this overgrown
child
uh i married a guy that looks like you
know a 15 year old sporting his first
goatee
and she just wants masculinity in the
marriage but she can't have it so it's a
very sad and tragic thing meanwhile this
guy
has been
conditioned by society that toxic
masculinity is bad and you know we want
to have
equality of the sexes and this is what
he's been told and so he's been living
that way and now he's being told by his
wife no i actually want you to be a man
because that's what you are and he's
sitting there like oh really
you mean you want me to be a man you
want the man to be a man i i didn't know
i'm sorry
because that's the reality no matter
what we're told by society we're trying
you know society tries to condition us
away from
our
natural
inclinations you know from from natural
law in many ways but no matter what they
do it can't change it
is that in in most scenarios a woman is
with a man because she wants a man the
man's with a woman because he wants a
woman
and yes
she wants you to take the lead
now
she might not like it when you put it
like that okay so
deciding where you're gonna eat she
might not want you to say honey i'll
take the lead here i'll tell you what
we're gonna eat she just wants you to
say that she just wants you to do it
decide where you're gonna eat and tell
her and you know
she'll live with it so that's good
advice that one you can take to the bank
all the rest of it you can toss into the
wood chipper like so much else that we
get on tick tock
and uh i think i'll just get to
grilling these pieces of charcoal that i
have here
uh remember good ranchers is where you
should get all your meat
and also
have a great labor day
you communist